and finally new rule it's time somebody
called out Donald Trump for something
he's doing that I don't think anyone has
caught on to yet he's a big liar when he
announced he was running the first time
he said I don't need anybody's money I'm
using my own money I'm not using donors
I don't care I'm really rich but he's
not really rich and he's used plenty of
other people's money
90% of his 2016 campaign was funded by
other people's money his old reason for
being there is a lie this notion of I
can't be bought because I have so much
money I don't care about money anymore
no the exact opposite is true
the man is constantly for sale that
wasn't toilet paper on his shoe it's a
price tag
he grubs for every penny he wasn't above
cheating his charity Trump University
was a pyramid scheme he just put a g7
meeting in one of his golf clubs there
is $9 he has ever left on the table
since he took office
he's worried about Ukrainian corruption
the only time corruption bothers Donald
Trump is when he's not in on it
if your country pays in cash Saudi
Arabia pays cash you can literally get
away with murder you know even I have a
little money history with this guy
remember mr. president 2013 when you
sued me because I publicly offered you
five million dollars if you could prove
you were not the son of an orangutan
it was a joke but when you heard five
million dollars like a bum who chases a
dollar on the sidewalk tied to a string
you could not resist chasing it into
court well you lost that one
tonight I want to give you another
chance to get some money out of me now
you and I have been going back and forth
on whether you will leave office if you
lose the election I mean you have one
guy on television I'm telling you he's
not believing he's going to win and that
he's not believing so in 2024 he won't
leave I'm telling you this is a serious
person thank you serious person is
serious person I will bet you a million
dollars right now that if you lose the
20/20 election I'm right and you won't
leave and what am I saying
this is Donald Trump we're talking about
like he'd ever pony up even if he lost a
bet that would involve two things he's
never done admit defeat and pay a bill
[Applause]
forget the bet I got a better idea how
about this
just take my check for $1,000,000 my
check for a million and I bet I could
get another thousand people just from
here to the beach
including Malibu of course who would pay
that much to see you resign
and to those out there who are saying my
god bill are you suggesting we paid this
man to go away yes that's exactly what
I'm suggesting
in fact I'm insisting celebrities do
nothing but waste their money on stupid
stupid crazy [ __ ] like castles and jewel
encrusted crucifixes and shark tanks and
private islands here's something I could
spend on and no it was doing some good
let's let's speak to Donald Trump in the
only language he is ever really
understood my whole life has been money
I want money I want money greedy I was
greedy greedy I want more money more
money it's not like he was hiding it
it goes back to his childhood from the
moment his father created his first
teenage shell company money money money
makes Donnie a winner daddy loves good
boy who gets money
so so mr. president it's really very
simple you love money we hate you
take our money you could finally be the
billionaire you always pretended you
were yes I said billionaire coz the kind
of money I could get from just off the
top of my head
Oprah cher Madonna Gaga bono jay-z
Beyonce pink Rihanna
uh sure Pharrell Eminem and that's just
the ones with one name
singers actors athletes everyone [ __ ]
hates you
[Applause]
here's a list of every single person in
show business
[Applause]
this is a list of every single person in
show business with the names of those
who do not hate you close down finally
let us not forget that millions and
millions of not so rich and famous
people who despise you too Americans of
modest means who would happily chip in 5
10 20 bucks or pawn their wedding rings
whatever it took and that's why tonight
I am formally announcing the formation
of my national crowdfunding platform to
bribe trip President Trump to leave I
mean sir win and we call it prick
starter
[Applause]
you